(INDISTINCT CHATTER)
-Oh.
-(CAT MEOWS)
(GAGGING) Penis cat.
ROMAN ROY:
"This wine is triumphant?"
No?
-"Your vagina trumpets."
-GERRI KILLMAN: Shh!
It's uh...
"I triumph from the truth."
Oh, right, of course. Truth.
Love it. It's the best, right?
Truth.
He seems cool.
Everyone, I promise not to
interrupt your tipple for long,
but I just wanted to take
a brief moment
to welcome you
to our funny, little house
and to let our guests know
that what you're drinking
is Hank Pierce's
Break Bumper!
ALL: The Break Bumper!
The recipe is stolen,
no one believes,
from the wallet
of Teddy Roosevelt's valet.
(CHUCKLING)
Cheers, everyone.
-Cheers. Welcome.
-ALL: Cheers.
Yeah, I'm actually getting
my second PhD right now
-in Africana studies from Brown.
-Oh?
Wow, so, you'll be
a double doctor?
(CHUCKLES) Well, the second PhD
is much harder.
You know, five years
is an absolute gauntlet.
Oh, I'm sure. But just think,
once you're done,
you won't have to waste
the 12 seconds it takes
-to look up something
on Wikipedia.
-(TOM SNICKERS)
But seriously, though.
Well done.
-That's quite an achievement.
-Thank you.
-Connor Roy! Maxim Pierce.
-Mm-hmm. Hi.
The man who would be king.
-(CHUCKKLES)
-Don Quixote of Iowa
tilting its straw polls.
Yeah, I got a big ol' tent
and everyone's welcome.
-(LAUGHS)
-So, are you in politics?
-Sort of. Brookings Institute.
-Ah! Brookings!
Yes, of course. A fine,
elite establishment.
Oh, I didn't take you
for a fan.
I thought you were on the whole
"abolish the federal reserve,
fluoride is poison,
pissing in jars" end of things.
No, I'm actually on the liberty
and justice for all
end of things, but hey,
different strokes.
ROMAN: Mm. Here comes Ken.
Spiraling down.
Uh, Rome. You remember Naomi.
Ah, yeah, that's right.
From the... from the thing.
NAOMI PIERCE:
Oh, the thing?
Where you tried to order
my family's legacy
over the phone
like an Uber Eats.
-Of course.
-(CHUCKLES) Burn.
-NAOMI PIERCE: How are you?
-That's the thing.
Uh, you know, I'm well.
I'm very well. I'm...
working real hard, you know.
-Yeah?
-ROMAN: Yeah. No.
Not at all. Really. Maybe.
Who knows?
What he meant to say
is that he's really passionate
about maintaining the integrity
of the customer facing brands.
-Wow! (CHUCKLES)
-Yeah.